Mesurer une superposition quantique est aussi aléatoire que de lancer une pièce, mais jusqu'où peut-on pousser cette
analogie avant qu'elle atteigne ses limites ? On le découvrira aujourd'hui dans Qiskit in the
Classroom. Bienvenue dans Qiskit in the Classroom, une série de vidéos où l'on décortique un concept fondamental que tu pourrais
rencontrer dans un cours lié à l'informatique quantique. Chaque vidéo est accompagnée d'un module interactif dont le lien se trouve dans la
description ci-dessous, alors assure-toi de le consulter. Aujourd'hui, on parle de l'un des principes fondamentaux au cœur de
la théorie quantique : la superposition. Dans notre expérience quotidienne, les objets ont toujours des caractéristiques bien définies — leur position, leur taille,
leur forme, leur couleur — tout à leur sujet est déterminé et certain, même si nous, l'observateur, ne l'avons pas encore mesuré. Dans le
monde quantique, ce n'est pas nécessairement le cas. Un objet quantique peut se trouver dans ce qu'on appelle une superposition de
plusieurs états classiquement autorisés, qui lors de la mesure va aléatoirement s'effondrer sur l'un de ces
états. Mesurer un état de superposition, c'est comme lancer une pièce — il n'y a aucun moyen de savoir à l'avance de quel côté elle va
tomber. Cet indéterminisme fondamental est un aspect inconfortable de la mécanique quantique qu'Einstein lui-même avait du mal
à accepter. Il a dit la célèbre phrase « Dieu ne joue pas aux dés » à propos de ce hasard. Mais comme on va le voir, Dieu joue effectivement aux dés, ou dans
notre cas il lance des pièces. Mais il y a plus : ces pièces sont truquées. Mesurer une superposition quantique ressemble peut-être à
lancer une pièce à certains égards, mais la superposition elle-même est bien plus riche et complexe qu'un état
probabiliste classique. Pour le constater, on va réfléchir au fonctionnement d'une pièce classique et contraster cela avec notre
pièce quantique qu'on va explorer en utilisant Qiskit sur un ordinateur quantique IBM. D'abord, une pièce classique. C'est
assez simple : on lance la pièce et elle tombe soit face en haut, soit face en bas, avec 50 % de chance pour chaque. Bien qu'en principe on puisse
calculer de quel côté la pièce va tomber si on connaissait les conditions initiales précises de la pièce et exactement quelle force et quel couple
ont été appliqués lors du lancer, en pratique il n'y a aucun moyen de savoir a priori de quel côté la pièce
va tomber. C'est pourquoi on utilise le lancer de pièce comme exemple canonique d'un état probabiliste classique où le
résultat est essentiellement aléatoire. Si je lançais cette pièce mille fois et enregistrais le nombre de fois où elle tombe face en haut
et face en bas, j'obtiendrais un histogramme qui ressemble à quelque chose comme ça. Donc on a les comptes sur l'axe Y,
et ce peut être soit face en haut soit face en bas,
et l'histogramme montrerait environ 500 comptes de chaque, à une certaine
fluctuation statistique près. On peut créer un état similaire en utilisant un qubit sur notre ordinateur quantique. Comme le lancer de pièce, un
qubit peut aussi être mesuré dans deux états possibles : zéro et un. Si on applique quelque chose appelé une porte Hadamard au
qubit, cela le met dans une superposition égale de zéro et un. Voici une
visualisation de ce circuit, qu'on appelle un circuit diagram. Ici, le fil du dessus est le
qubit, et les opérations appliquées au qubit apparaissent sous forme de boîtes sur les fils. La porte Hadamard est représentée par cette boîte
étiquetée H, et la mesure est représentée par cette boîte grise avec le petit symbole de mesure. Elle envoie cette
mesure sur un bit classique — ce fil à deux lignes. Donc comme le qubit est dans une superposition égale de 0 et un, quand
on le mesure, il y a 50 % de chance qu'on mesure zéro et 50 % qu'on mesure
un. On exprime cet état de superposition quantique comme s = 1 / racine
de 2 fois |0⟩ + 1 / racine de 2 fois |1⟩, où les carrés de chacun de ces
coefficients — aussi appelés amplitudes — sont les probabilités de mesurer chaque état. Ainsi, appliquer la porte Hadamard
est l'analogue de lancer une pièce. Et tout comme on a lancé la pièce mille fois pour examiner les
statistiques de la pièce tombant face en haut ou face en bas, on peut faire quelque chose de similaire dans Qiskit avec notre pièce quantique.
On va utiliser un primitif de Qiskit appelé sampler, qui va répéter le circuit plusieurs fois pour échantillonner les statistiques
de l'état résultant. Avec mille échantillons du circuit ci-dessus, on obtient quelque chose qui ressemble fondamentalement à l'identique
à l'histogramme de la pièce classique, à quelques fluctuations statistiques près. Alors, c'est tout ? Les superpositions
quantiques sont essentiellement les mêmes qu'un état probabiliste classique, similaire au lancer d'une pièce ? Pas tout à fait. Ce serait
une vidéo assez courte si c'était le cas. Pour voir notre première différence clé, je vais essayer quelque chose de légèrement différent avec ma pièce classique. Au lieu de
simplement la laisser tomber sur la table en tombant soit face en haut, soit face en bas, je vais lancer la pièce et l'attraper
en plein air entre mes paumes. Maintenant, la pièce n'est pas face en haut ou en bas, mais est plutôt soit face à gauche
soit face à droite. Donc la logique nous dit que cela devrait aussi avoir une probabilité 50/50 d'être
soit face à gauche soit face à droite. Pour mesurer face à gauche ou à droite sur notre pièce quantique, on peut faire ce qu'on a fait avec la pièce classique :
mesurer le long d'un axe différent. Nos mesures standard sur l'ordinateur quantique se font le long de l'axe vertical,
tout comme la mesure habituelle face en haut ou en bas de la pièce classique. Mais on peut aussi demander à notre pièce quantique si elle est
face à gauche ou à droite. On appelle ces deux états le long de l'axe x : plus ou moins.
Pour cela, on utilise le primitif de Qiskit appelé estimator. Pour compliquer les choses un peu, au lieu de renvoyer un histogramme comme
sampler le fait, estimator nous donnera la valeur d'attente de n'importe quelle observable du qubit. Pour
comprendre cette valeur d'attente, disons que tu gagnes un dollar chaque fois que la pièce tombe face en haut et perds un dollar quand elle
tombe face en bas. La valeur d'attente est la somme d'argent que tu peux espérer gagner en moyenne à chaque lancer de pièce. Comme tu es
également susceptible de gagner ou de perdre un dollar, la valeur d'attente serait zéro. Le même raisonnement peut être appliqué
au qubit. Quand on trouve la valeur d'attente de x, quand on applique x à l'état plus on
obtient la valeur +1, et à l'état moins on obtient moins un. Donc si on avait une
distribution 50/50, on obtiendrait une valeur d'attente de zéro. Mais on n'obtient pas ça — on obtient une valeur d'attente de plus un,
ce qui signifie que la pièce est toujours mesurée comme étant dans l'état plus le long de l'axe x. Ce serait comme lancer une
pièce, l'attraper et garantir que la face serait toujours tournée vers la droite. C'est parce qu'une
superposition n'est pas juste une distribution de probabilité. Rappelle-toi comment on exprime un état
quantique : s est égal à C0 fois l'état 0 plus C1
fois l'état 1, où chacun de ces coefficients est complexe, c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
à la fois des parties réelles et imaginaires. Ils nous renseignent donc sur les probabilités, mais ils cachent aussi une autre quantité appelée
la phase. Un coefficient C peut s'écrire
ainsi : C est égal à la magnitude multipliée par cette phase, où ce phi est la
phase. C'est un peu comme la phase d'une onde ou la position des crêtes et des creux d'une onde. Si deux ondes sont en phase
l'une avec l'autre, c'est-à-dire que leurs crêtes et leurs creux s'alignent, elles vont se combiner pour former une onde deux fois plus
haute. On appelle ça l'interférence constructive. Si elles sont déphasées
comme ça, alors elles interfèrent de façon destructive et s'annulent complètement. Pour voir comment la phase peut provoquer
une interférence dans notre pièce quantique, essayons d'appliquer la porte Hadamard deux fois au lieu d'une seule. Classiquement,
ça n'aurait aucun sens — si appliquer la porte Hadamard équivaut à lancer une pièce, alors on ne peut pas lancer une pièce qui est déjà en train de tourner. Mais voyons ce qui
se passe quantiquement. On applique donc la porte Hadamard deux fois et on échantillonne l'état résultant.
Étonnamment, on n'a plus une probabilité 50/50 — l'histogramme résultant montre que dans tous les cas, on mesure le
qubit dans l'état zéro. Donc la deuxième porte Hadamard a ramené le qubit à l'état zéro d'où on avait commencé. C'est
un peu difficile à voir au premier abord, mais c'est grâce à l'interférence de l'état quantique. Mais plutôt que
d'interférer dans l'espace réel comme une vraie onde, l'interférence se produit dans l'espace d'information abstrait du qubit.
La deuxième porte Hadamard a causé l'interférence constructive de la partie zéro de la superposition, tandis que la partie un de la
superposition a interféré de façon destructive et a disparu. Explorons davantage. On peut changer la phase en utilisant
quelque chose appelé une porte de phase. Donc maintenant, appliquons une porte Hadamard pour créer la superposition, appliquons un déphasage de
pi radians, puis appliquons la deuxième porte Hadamard. Maintenant, il semble que notre pièce quantique tombe toujours dans l'état un.
Le déphasage de pi a interverti les parties de l'état de superposition qui étaient en phase et hors phase l'une avec l'autre.
Donc l'état final est un au lieu de zéro. Ce serait comme lancer une pièce et, pendant qu'elle est en l'air, pouvoir
appliquer une opération qui garantirait qu'elle tombe toujours face en haut ou toujours face en bas selon l'opération.
Impossible dans le cas classique, mais pas dans le cas quantique. Ce qu'on a appris de ces expériences c'est que
cette nouvelle capacité de la pièce quantique est due à sa phase — une qualité que possède une superposition quantique mais pas une
distribution de probabilité classique. Donc le lancer de pièce habituel n'est en réalité pas une si bonne analogie pour une
superposition, car il ne dit rien sur cette phase. Je pense qu'on peut faire mieux. Je vais faire une autre
expérience avec notre pièce. J'ai la pièce posée sur la table face en haut. Pour la mettre face en bas, je peux juste la retourner. C'est
l'équivalent computationnel d'une porte NOT. Disons qu'on veut construire une opération qui, appliquée deux fois, serait
équivalente à cette porte NOT. On peut appeler cette opération la racine carrée de NOT. Réfléchis donc à ce qu'on fait physiquement
quand on applique la porte NOT : on la fait pivoter de 180° autour, par exemple, de l'axe x. Donc si on faisait pivoter la pièce
de seulement 90° autour de l'axe x, cela nous donnerait la racine carrée de NOT. On a donc appliqué
notre racine carrée de NOT et la pièce est juste posée sur sa tranche. On peut demander si elle est face en haut ou face en bas. Eh bien,
clairement, elle n'est ni l'un ni l'autre. Mais on pourrait ajouter une étape au processus de mesure pour la forcer à être face en haut ou face en bas. Maintenant,
la pièce tombera soit face en haut soit face en bas avec une probabilité égale. Encore une fois, en principe on pourrait prédire
de quel côté elle tombera, mais en pratique c'est suffisamment difficile à prédire pour être essentiellement aléatoire. Si je veux
mesurer si elle est face à gauche ou à droite, je peux l'aplatir dans cette direction de façon similaire, et elle nous donnera encore une probabilité
50/50 de gauche et de droite. Mais dans cette dimension — face devant ou derrière —
la face est déjà tournée vers l'avant, donc 100 % du temps on mesurera qu'elle est face devant. Donc tandis que les mesures x et z
donnaient des résultats aléatoires, la mesure Y donnera toujours le même résultat. Si on repense à l'expérience de lancer de pièce quantique
de la section précédente, c'est reminiscent de la façon dont la pièce quantique s'est comportée après avoir appliqué
la porte Hadamard. Le qubit était mesuré soit zéro soit 1 avec une probabilité 50/50 dans la direction Z, mais
toujours dans l'état plus et jamais dans l'état moins le long de X. Cela suggère qu'une pièce debout sur sa tranche est peut-être
une meilleure façon de visualiser un état de superposition d'un qubit qu'une pièce tournant follement dans les airs.
Appliquons une porte racine carrée de NOT sur notre pièce quantique dans Qiskit. On a ce circuit simple,
puis on utilise estimator pour vérifier la valeur d'attente des trois observables X, Y et Z, qui sont en quelque sorte
comme faire s'effondrer notre pièce le long de chacune des trois dimensions, comme je viens de montrer. Les valeurs d'attente sont donc 0,
moins un et 0 pour X, Y et Z respectivement. C'est le même résultat qu'on a
obtenu pour la rotation de racine carrée de NOT appliquée à la pièce classique. En fait, il y a une analogie précise entre la
pièce et l'état du qubit. On peut maintenant visualiser l'état du qubit comme un vecteur pointant dans la direction de la face
sur la pièce, normal à la surface de la pièce. Donc face en haut, ou l'état zéro
sur la pièce quantique, est équivalent à un vecteur pointant directement vers le haut. Face en bas, ou un, pointe directement vers le bas. Et toute
superposition égale de 0 et un pointe horizontalement. La phase de l'état quantique détermine la direction horizontale exacte,
par exemple si elle pointe le long de l'axe x, le long de l'axe Y, ou quelque part
entre les deux. Ce vecteur est connu sous le nom de vecteur de Bloch, et il détermine de façon complète et unique l'état quantique d'un seul
qubit. On peut maintenant réimaginer chaque porte qu'on a vue dans cette vidéo comme une rotation ou une série de rotations sur la
pièce, ou de façon équivalente sur le vecteur de Bloch. La porte NOT est une rotation de
180° autour de l'axe x. Appliquée à notre état zéro ou face en haut, elle bascule vers l'état
en bas, ou un. La racine carrée de NOT est juste 90° autour de ce même axe x, à partir de
l'état face en haut — cela la fait pivoter vers la face devant. Une porte de phase est une rotation de phi autour de l'axe Z. Comme
face en haut est aligné avec l'axe Z, cela ne fait rien à la pièce. La porte Hadamard est un peu plus délicate — on
l'avait d'abord comparée à lancer une pièce, la faisant tourner de façon incontrôlable dans les airs. Mais la porte Hadamard est en réalité une
rotation déterministe et contrôlée de la pièce, comme toutes les autres portes. La porte Hadamard s'effectue en faisant pivoter de 90°
autour de l'axe Y puis de 180° autour de l'axe x. Donc appliquée à l'état face en haut, elle
finit par être face à droite. Donc il n'y a rien d'aléatoire dans un état de superposition quantique ni dans aucune des
opérations standard qu'on effectue sur le qubit. Chaque opération est déterministe et réversible. Le seul moment où le
hasard entre en jeu, c'est quand on décide de mesurer l'état quantique. Qu'un état quantique soit même dans une
superposition est vraiment dans l'œil de celui qui regarde. Comme tu l'as probablement rencontré, on est libre de choisir notre
système de coordonnées — X, Y et Z peuvent pointer dans n'importe quelles trois directions orthogonales. Donc
si on a une superposition de 0 et un dans un système de coordonnées, on peut définir un nouveau système de coordonnées, ou une nouvelle
base, dans laquelle l'état pointe purement dans la direction Z plus et n'est donc pas dans un état de superposition.
Donc quand on dit qu'un qubit est dans une superposition, on doit aussi définir notre système de coordonnées ou
notre base. Tu peux terminer ce module avec l'impression qu'on vient juste de retirer tout le mystère de la mécanique quantique.
Après tout, l'un des aspects supposément les plus étranges — l'état de superposition d'un qubit — est en réalité aussi simple qu'un
vecteur tridimensionnel. Mais garde à l'esprit que la pièce n'est toujours qu'une analogie, et même le vecteur de Bloch n'est
qu'un outil de visualisation. Pour calculer les probabilités des résultats de mesure, on ne peut pas dire ce que fait un état quantique
avant qu'il soit mesuré, car vérifier cela nécessite une mesure. On discutera de
cette énigme — quelle est la véritable nature d'un état quantique — et de comment le phénomène quantique de l'intrication peut nous aider à
l'élucider, dans un autre épisode de Qiskit in the Classroom entièrement consacré à l'inégalité de Bell. En attendant, si tu
veux jouer avec des pièces quantiques pour apprendre par toi-même les états de superposition d'un qubit et comment les contrôler,
rends-toi sur le module de pièces quantiques dont le lien se trouve dans la description. Merci d'avoir regardé et à la prochaine fois.